what is going on everybody and welcome
to a video of my were about my desks so
many people have noticed in my videos
that it's like it doesn't look like
you're sitting are you standing at a
desk you know and the topic of my desk
seems to come up pretty frequently and
so I figured I could have a video and
just point people to it from now on so
yes it is a standing desk and for some
reason some people find that like
offensive like when they find out I
haven't standing desk it's like an it's
like an attack at them for sitting I
don't care do whatever you want okay and
so if you're offended by my standing
desk
get over it so so first of all why did I
get a standing desk so a lot of people
have these notion that like a standing
desk is like for health reasons or
something and I mean to an extent it can
be but actually I just needed a desk and
so I just started looking around for new
desks and kind of poked around into the
idea of being able to stand I thought it
sounded cool that I could stand for
maybe a couple hours a day or something
because being a programmer I'm sitting
at my desk like all day long and it
would be nice to stand from time to time
so so then I started looking at a
standing desk and I thought an
adjustable standing desk would make the
most sense that way I could sit and
stand at will and that's kind of what I
got this desk for now fast forward two
years or really honestly about two
months after I bought the desk I just
stood all the time I'm it really took
about two months before I kicked the
chair like I don't even have a chair in
my room anymore and it didn't take too
long to come to that point but it's not
that I think that that's what where
everyone will go I just it just turned
out that I really enjoyed I preferred to
stand it's more of a preference I'm not
doing it for health reasons I even had
someone was like oh a standing desk
you're just exchanging back pain for
knee pain and it's like I have no knee
pain I don't have any pain standing at
the desk the only thing I would say is
if you get a standing desk I have these
like feet mats foot mat and it's kind of
like a gel mat for your feet and if you
can stand in that and
like either bare feet or socks no foot
pain but whenever I like I'm wearing my
shoes and I stand on the mat my heels
start to hurt um or if I'm not standing
on the map my feet hurt and I was a
waiter for quite a bit of the early
years of my working years now I don't
have a job and I foot pain was like
always an issue for me I always have
foot pain and I was a runner and I would
always have foot pain while I was
running and then after I got the
standing desk like my foot pain from
during and after running like totally
went away now I'm not saying the
standing desk cures foot pain it's just
anecdotal that I mean I did sort of see
that benefit but that again is not I
wouldn't get it standing desk for health
reasons at all the other like unforeseen
benefit for me for a standing desk or
just an adjustable desk really is that
when depending on what you're doing like
if I'm working at my computer and using
my keyboard I want the desk to kind of
allow my arms my forearms and my wrists
to almost be straight and like have as
little can't as possible in there but if
I am like putting something together and
working with I don't know raspberry
pines and bread boards or if I like when
I was putting together my 3d printer
it's really useful to adjust the desk up
like you generally want it much closer
to your face when you're doing something
like with your hands on a surface so
it's actually really cool to be able to
put three literals do that and put it at
the exact level that you need so that's
another huge benefit that like I didn't
even see that coming but it's like one
of my favorite things about the desk now
is like and that's why I bought a second
one and that's actually pretty much a
carbon copy of this desk just not as
long I want to say this is 7 feet and
that's like 5 or 6 feet I should be able
to eyeball that and know the answer but
I'm gonna guess five feet anyways yeah
that's so I bought that one purely for
that reason like I don't actually like I
don't work at that desk and I don't I
never sit that desk
it's that height so I can raise and
lower at one I'm working on stuff out
that desk so anyways
kind of an unforeseen benefit of the
desks now in terms of you know these
desks specifically you know
like I said I've only had this one maybe
for about two years now
and it's held up really well so some
people say and like biggest question is
like with two posts rather than like say
for total legs is does it have wobble I
assure you it doesn't have wobble but
some people see wobble in my videos and
I even have one person accused me of
using a green screen because of the
wobble um I I don't have a green screen
but it does wobble and like if I jump up
and down you'll see things wobbled but I
was jumping up and down and I'm not
touching my desk it's the floor so my
old house I had a cement foundation
right here I have a pure beam so it's
the desk is not insecure it's the floor
that has its people anyway so that is
yes annoying but it has nothing to do
with the desk the desk is actually super
stable and I actually put my computer on
it now they do make like a little nook
thing that like hangs under the desk and
you like screw it into the desk and that
makes a whole lot of sense I wish I had
one send me one but even on the desk
like it doesn't give you any wobble like
I've put so much weight on this desk and
no problem so yeah so I I just love
these desks I can't recommend them
enough and the other cool thing I got
with the desk there's like so many
options when you go through there's
there must be like 30 steps of like
extra junk that you can get mostly I
have the desk I got like an inlet cut
like so like where you stand it cuts in
just a little bit has a little bit of a
curve I got like the bamboo type surface
sometimes I wish I got a white one
instead so like when I take pictures of
things it's like a little more crisp I
think if I got another desk send me
another desk uh it would be a white one
uh so so the other thing is the
programmable like up-and-down so I'll go
over there in a second and they like the
basic one just has arrows and then
there's another the other one that's
programmable where you can program like
five preset settings and that is super
useful definitely get that if you've got
one of the does
so I'll just show you so you can might
hit these arrows like up and down and
the desk goes up and down or I've got
one of my USB cords I'm just going to
move that real quick you can hit just a
preset button and the desk just goes to
a specific height which again is super
useful I'll set preset Heights depending
on what I'm doing and especially like
when you're going between sitting and
standing it was very convenient to just
like hit the button kick the chair out
from under you and stand up so yeah
super cool I would definitely get one of
those but if you're just someone that's
like looking to maybe get into it the
other things are like these like desk
they like sit on top of your desk and
then you like crank it up a little bit I
mean those are okay the reason I didn't
go with one of those is because it takes
up more desk space not like I don't need
any help
cluttering my desk it is it's always a
freaking mess before I do any recording
I clean up for you guys okay now
actually it's not for you guys it's for
me because you guys would make fun of me
so yeah so anyway I just wouldn't want
one of those things so but they also
make like manually cranking desks where
you can like crank it up and stuff him I
mean these are definitely expensive
desks like if you have it motorized I
really do like it and like I said it
holds a lot of weight I would feel
totally fine putting like a hundred
pounds plus on this desk like I'm pretty
confident I could sit on the desk and
raise and lower it and they'd be fine
so I weigh like a smidge over a hundred
pounds so anyway that's all in the
standing desk hopefully that answers
everybody's questions again it wasn't
sponsored in any way but if they want to
sponsor let me know I would totally give
you guys ad placement and because I love
these desks and if you want to continue
sitting hey man or girl that's totally
fine I don't judge you guys I don't know
that it's necessarily more healthier or
less healthy like you can definitely
hold a terrible posture while at a
standing desk because there's no
different than standing regularly right
nobody like lots of people have horrible
sitting posture and lots of people have
horrible standing posture
so I'm not convinced that it's gonna
help your posture in any way the amount
of calories extra that you'll be burning
by standing if you're somebody who's
looking to lose weight the amount of
calories you'll burn by standing is
going to be insignificant so I wouldn't
get it for that reason we just get it
because I just like standing at a desk
and like everybody sits at the desk and
like most people just have never
probably worked at a standing desk and I
just I just prefer it that's it and then
the added benefits like I said I've like
if I'm typing I want it at one height
but if I'm working on something I want
it even higher and I forget how high
these desks can go but it's pretty high
I would raise this one but I've got so
many like cords that are threaded I'm a
little nervous to put it too high like
the desk oh I think we know we haven't
reached them maybe that's the max okay
the max looks like 51 centimeters it's
basically the height of my like well
it's at like I don't know my chest level
right now which is pretty freakin high
that's pretty cool
anyways so you can get pretty high that
like I said I think that was 51
centimeters centimeters would that make
sense I don't actually know what the
measurement is here I'm making myself
look totally stupid right now
which is true so anyways okay so that's
it for now questions comments whatever
flow further than below if you've got
other pressing questions about something
even unprogrammed related let me know if
you want to get one of the desks cool I
guess I could put a link in the
description but you could probably find
them and yeah cool so I'll see you guys
later it's definitely in inches
centimeters what a freaking idiot